you will never forget doing a celebrity
beach volleyball contest calling it with
Nick Cannon and another person watching
the Backstreet Boys win but when that
other person is the most decorated beach
volleyball Olympian of all time you'll
definitely never forget it and I did
won't ever forget it Kerri
walsh-jennings that was really fun we'll
always have Miami
it was happy to be here with you in the
South Bay you got it happy to be here
too I mean but that was that was a nutty
event that we were at last year I
honestly felt like such a fish out of
water and I'm like Tom can enrich like
what is this trio the Backstreet Boys I
can't believe em burr the details I mean
there was trash talking there was a lot
going on well I mean and then the
Backstreet Boys I forget who it was but
there was actually there was at one
point when you and I were calling the
action in quotes I forget there was an
actual like real dig out of the sand and
you were like whoa no we celebrate the
good that was fantastic and thrilled to
have here because I know we were talking
last summer like no thirdly busy and
we'll talk about you know what we're
what you're here to talk about what the
league is what your time up you okay we
will talk about that in a moment but I
just want to get into what's going on
with you first what are you up to oh
goodness gracious well mommy head okay
you know as number one how many kids
you're clearly f3 they just had their
birthday so an eight nine and five it's
awesome okay so fun I am competing I had
two surgeries in my offseason okay and
now I'm back okay and I'm ready to win
I've been losing and it just pisses me
off and it does not sit well and then
we're starting this new tour so P 1440
so I am now an entrepreneur you know I'm
just trying to do what I can do okay and
before we get in that tour for a second
how did you get into beach volleyball
how did you get into that to begin with
you know I grew up in Santa Cruz I went
to Stanford playing indoor volleyball my
whole entire life from when I was a baby
in Santa Cruz till I was a Stanford I
avoid a beach volleyball because I look
like an idiot
like I was so ashamed of my skills I
felt good endure but I played in the
indoor Olympics in 2000 and then I
didn't want to go play in Europe and so
misty may-treanor Misty May at the time
was looking for a new partner she was my
idol and I said I might as well put my
ego and check and go give it a try out
and that one tryout changed my life I
met my future husband that day and I met
my future partner whom I changed I swear
to God there will be a movie about this
one you know which day it is it was
early January of 2001 so your husband
two times over
that's unbelievers for you ever try hope
so yeah I play basketball when two
highschool and Archbishop MIDI in San
Jose and I played basketball and we had
really good teams I was really terrible
but I looked at it as cross-training for
volleyball it made me stronger tougher
good change it for my body but I was not
good so who's the best athlete that's
not technically a beach volleyball er
that you've been around which tried it
and who could be really damn good at it
Oh have you ever been around like
another basketball player or somebody I
mean well here in the South Bay you know
Luke Walton plays a lot he loves the
sport so they're down I don't know what
street they play on but they're playing
all the time we used to have like pickup
yeah I mean would they get their buddies
out there we used to have tnv Tuesday
night volleyball and yeah there Pete
Carroll will be out there and all of our
friends Richard Jefferson plays you know
here in the South Bay so you know all
the MB airs like when they retire they
should come out to our sport this recess
because they're so physical
obviously well it's not to say Pete
Carroll was out there yeah we'd play
right in front of his house in Hermosa
and Glenna his wife would come out like
it was just a good time that was when my
boys were young I haven't done it in
years so no kidding so sunsetting yes
your mosa yeah glistening over the
Pacific Ocean
pardon me and then all of a sudden Pete
Carroll's wife comes out with something
like six on six she was back row
superstar
she was really good about the mindset
and the enthusiasm yeah and we'd have
like these special it always felt like
there's a celebrity athlete guest you
know we had some track stars come out
and
yeah I don't know our sport is for
everyone you know but I really do like
when the basketballers come out and play
I know that like all the NHL errs who
live in the South Bay on the Kings they
love our sport too right it's like the
ultimate cross-training + ultimate
lifestyle right you know and it's a
blast it's a blast we need to get you
out there I would well I just don't know
if I have the the hops well then you
just have to be craftier how can I be
crafty er is it a I think you might get
my service game going or something like
it sir I mean just like with anything if
you have the fundamentals down so you
need good ball control if you have good
ball control then you can just be a
ninja and place the ball if you have a
good serve that's a good start okay but
you just gotta be able to pass the ball
what if I'm my best part of my game is
rotating the substitution the armor with
this attitude we got going on right now
because right now you already defeated
so I will have you coach and commentate
but not playing well I mean I don't ski
I apres ski I want to go to the beach I
bring a book you know and so I mean I
don't it's been a while since I've ran
on the beach or anything like that
but I'm willing to try if you would be
my tutor we discussed this we you
sometimes you forget in the haze of
watching the Backstreet Boys play
celebrity volleyball yes but we kind of
did you know in a break you were saying
you know you should try you you
definitely come out because I know that
you are with Kerri walsh-jennings here
on the Richards Joe I know you are a
huge ambassador for your sport you've
mentioned no fewer than three or four
times and everybody should come out and
see and I give you the floor on that to
let folks who are listening and watching
right now about where they can find the
sport have you been I have not I have
not I fully admit
unfortunately my my biggest platform on
it was the one that we were seeing in
front of us
Beach I do watch it all the time um
whenever it's on in the Olympics I do so
once every four years we got your
attention
well volleyball indoor and Beach is the
number one sport at the Olympics okay
which says a lot no but the problem with
our sport is that we're only relative
once every four years because everyone
is good in the sport is only chasing
gold medals you know and so what we want
to do and what my job as the ambassador
that I love to be is to grow the game
and to get people like yourself talking
about the game that is so remarkable
that is so dynamic and finesse and it
has all these elements sex appeal but
it's family you know there really is a
lot of beautiful components to beach
volleyball the problem is we're not on
TV aside from the Olympics and we
haven't marketed the sport so with P
1440 that's where we aim to do things
differently we are gonna it's basically
a professional beach volleyball tour
best in the world will compete right now
if you want to compete on the world
stage I have to play with only another
American the Brasi is play with the bras
use the Germans with the Germans but
we're gonna okay we're gonna take off
those shackles and anyone can play with
anyone or inspired by the NBA you know
we want the best to show up we want to
get good prize money for all the glory
and grow the game you know iron sharpens
iron if the athletes the current date
athletes they're not making money it's a
hobby it's not a profession we call
ourselves professionals but we're not
and so we need to increase the
financials which is what P 1440 will do
and then the athletes and Team USA will
get better and better and better
yeah we just showed a bunch of the
screen grabs from your website hey 14:40
dot-com and the upcoming events late
September in San Jose Vegas let you know
if I can go it's right in the middle of
the NFL season San Diego and Huntington
Beach right down the road here in
California and how can kids get involved
cuz that's obviously the way that you
want to get something grassroots up
right is get these kids involved I'm
sure you already have your young uns in
the mix is that right I mean I might be
a little bit biased but they're pretty
incredible right
no the grassroots our sport is insane
it's like gangbusters there's millions
and millions of kids and families who
play our sport and we have just
partnered with locally the CB VA which
is a California beach volleyball
Association they have like 200
tournaments a year we're partnering with
them so they'll be the start of our
ladder and the climb to the top you know
we just want to bridge the gap right now
our sport is so fractioned off again
it's so healthy but we're a fraction and
we kind of see each other as enemy
instead of aligning and coming together
as a unit and so that's where we want to
do something different the kids love it
you know like the indoor are you
familiar with indoor scene I am it's
ginormous
it's huge right yeah because
n-c-double-a volleyball is a big time
deal for the women right you can earn a
scholarship there's ten scholarships per
team blah blah around the country and
now beach volleyball is that chick TWA
sport and so we have this feeder system
to the pros and to Team USA that we
really need to give them a home once
they graduate from college and so that
starts before they get to college with
the club training and all these things
and then after college with P 1440 the
tours and all these things fantastic and
then so you're a couple more minutes
left with Kerri walsh-jennings so you're
playing in 2020 right at the Olympics is
I got a lot of work to do if I'm being
honest with you but yes the goal is to
qualify qualifying starts actually this
year okay follow this year we have two
years to qualify and then yeah the plan
is to go and win it qualify first and
then go win a gold medal that bronze
just see it hurts me I hear what you're
saying but I mean you don't just show up
and just say look you know look at mine
just you know you don't want you don't
you want to earn your place is what
that's the first idea okay otherwise no
you know right now it's like my old
success is like kind of making me
insecure you know because I'm not there
anymore
yet I will be you know post surgeries
like this new me coming out I'm not
where I want to be you know so I'm
inspired by my past but know I got a lot
of work to do if I want to win gold in
Tokyo and I'm excited to do it okay and
then is that you think good gonna be it
for you or do you want some on the
olympic stage when i say that with all
due respect I mean I have three kids I
got a husband you know like I'm studying
to leave for I have eight tournaments in
ten weeks coming up okay and they're
largely in Europe so mom's going so mom
should be in jail for being away for
that long no no it's like the
give-and-take but that's the hardest
part of my job but my kids get it
they'll come visitin Switzerland and
she's got to make it work that works I
know you gotta you gotta make it work
for sure
and then you forgot about everything
that's going on with you and your burner
account your burner counter tell me
about it because I have no idea
come on there's no burn or Twitter
accounts in the in the volleyball you
know I mean
did you do your research everything we
do did you find any Kerri Walsh burger
guess Carolyn washes her regular Twitter
account
none at all short stuff one two three
good to see you Carrie you see a
checkout again P 1440 at p1 four four
zero dot-com for more information on how
to get involved and how to get this
sport more to the forefront and
certainly if it's coming through in your
area great to see you got it that's
Carrie Lee Walsh on Twitter with a blue
check mark Kerri walsh-jennings here in
the Richardson show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience